[Music]
on this friday night a community united
in grief
looks to the future we will work with
everybody to make sure that
this young boy is taken care of the
immense show of support for fayez afzal
the youngest survivor of the london
attack
canada's role in the g7's immunization
mission
a vaccine is only as effective if it is
in somebody's arm
the problems poorer nations face in
vaccinating people
magic mushrooms for medical use 100
is not addictive the potential benefits
to your mental health
plus attracting tourists and saboteurs
bc's popular sea to sky gondola is back
in business
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
farah nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us at the end of a very
heavy week
and we begin tonight in london ontario
the community is still struggling to
come to
terms with the loss of four members of
one family
they were deliberately struck and killed
on sunday while out for an evening walk
police believe they were targeted
because they were muslim
friday is a holy day for muslims but in
london ontario it holds even more
significance today
mike trolley is in the community tonight
with our top story
on this the holiest day of the week for
muslims congregants bowed their heads
as they listened to the imam recite from
the quran
their emotions raw and their thoughts no
doubt preoccupied
with the horrific murder of the afzal
family last sunday
i am expecting a lot of tears a lot of
people are going to be crying today
people were crying throughout as we
should be this is how we grieve
right like it's not beneath a person to
to to cry that is actually what makes us
human
down the street at yumna afzal's high
school the 15 year old is being
remembered as an honor roll student
and while still young a future leader
she also shared with one of her teachers
that she was interested in owning her
own business and eventually giving back
to her community
yumna he says spoke often of making her
family proud
her future by all accounts would have
been bright
they were an absolute success story and
everybody was was was looking forward to
what this family would do
in one way that's still possible two
separate online fundraisers have pulled
in roughly two million dollars
part of it will go to a trust fund for
the only survivor of the attack
nine-year-old fayez but relatives of the
afzal family
are also committed to sadaqa gerea a
muslim concept of leaving something
behind
that lives on after death to help others
like building a school or a hospital
that decision is for the future right
now the mosque is thinking about the
funerals
and what the future holds for fayez who
is still in hospital but expected to
make a full recovery
so we will work with everybody to make
sure that
this young boy is taken care of in the
best possible way nothing can replace
his parents
nothing can replace his family but we
will try our best to fill that void as
best as we can
but we will try our best to fill that
void as best as we can
and farah his future is at least
partially provided for a prominent
university which
wishes to remain anonymous called the
mosque and offered a full scholarship
for fayez when he comes of age
that maybe a little bit because he's
only nine still
incredible and mike this also shows the
support that's in the community
an anglican church organized a
multi-faith march which
got underway just a short time ago it
was raining where you are
what was the turnout like yeah
well it was raining just about half an
hour ago and we
expected that to impact the numbers it
really didn't
there were uh well over a thousand
people here
and there's going to be more joining
them as they walk the seven kilometers
from the
the scene of the attack all the way to
the london mosque and this is something
very important for the community
to be able to show support for this
family as well as to show that this
community can unite
against hate vara mike relay in london
thank you mps are calling on the trudeau
government to host an emergency summit
on islamophobia by the end of july
all those opposed to the motion will
please say nay
accordingly motions carry federal
lawmakers voted unanimously in support
of an ndp motion demanding a national
meeting in the wake of sunday's deadly
attack
the motion is non-binding and there's no
word yet on when the summit
may be held turning now to the g7 summit
in the uk
prime minister justin trudeau spent the
day on the english coast
with leaders of the world's wealthiest
nations they're trying to find
a way out of the global pandemic
canada's federal government is expected
to announce it will contribute to a
hundred million doses for people in need
the british prime minister has asked his
counterparts to come up with a plan to
supply
a billion doses but will that even be
enough
abigail beeman reports at this
g7 the spotlight is on the new american
president and joe biden filled the stage
with a big vaccine commitment
half a billion doses for lower income
countries
america will be the arsenal of vaccines
in our fight against global 19.
just as america was the arsenal
democracy during world war ii
g-7 leaders are expected to commit a
billion doses to vaccinate the world
and while our leader may be less in the
limelight canada will put up to
100 million into the pot broken down per
capita that's more than the u.s but
specifics are scant we'll be there doing
canada's full fair share
more details will be available over the
weekend canada was once criticized for
being the only g7 nation to
take doses from the kovacs facility
instead of donate them
one g7 watcher says now that our vaccine
rollout has picked up speed
pressure's on around the g7 table i
think they'll look
at justin trudeau right in the eyes face
to face and say
come on isn't it about time
experts hope the 1 billion dose
commitment goes beyond a flashy headline
to include a delivery road map
there are huge challenges in vaccinating
poorer and more remote parts of the
world
a vaccine is only as effective if it is
in somebody's arm
so many of these countries lack the
infrastructure to actually deliver them
vaccines have been thrown away and we
don't want to waste any
more there are also geopolitical
implications with two rising global
powers already filling the void
it's not a bad thing in itself that
china and russia are providing vaccines
that is helping to save lives but it's a
role that the west has not been playing
to the degree it should be
and were potentially losing ground in
terms of influence
some of the unanswered questions on the
canadian side include how much of this
is a re-announcement we know
part of the 100 million doses comes from
a previous kovacs commitment
we also don't know whether these surplus
donations will be made before
everyone in canada who wants two doses
has a chance
to get them abigail beeman global news
falmouth
england canada's commitment to share
doses internationally comes as this
country surpasses
all larger nations administering shots
domestically it's extraordinary given
the slow start to our vaccine rollout
canada also reached another milestone
today 10 percent of people are now
fully vaccinated and about 63 percent
have received at least
one dose there is strong demand for
vaccine and
strong supply too the federal government
has ordered more doses per capita than
any country in the world as eric
sorensen reports canada says it's
willing to share
but the priority is still here
from day one canadians have lined up for
their kovid shots and they've just kept
coming
i just really want to get my vaccine
canadian eagerness has vaulted this
country to global leadership and
vaccinations
it's really ramped up to be one of the
if not the top
vaccination campaign for first doses at
least in the world i think this is a
great accomplishment
global vaccine distribution began slowly
unevenly
by mid-february canada had fallen behind
many countries in initial doses
in april was in the middle of the pack
of leading vaccine nations
and now in mid-june canada has surged to
the top among larger countries
not only administering first doses to 63
percent of canadians
but showing no signs of slowing down
unlike some countries where vaccine
hesitancy is high or the pandemic was
played down
in canada get vaccinated with whatever
vaccine
is offered to us making sure that we get
needles into people's arms
across the political spectrum there has
been a consistent message
we need manitobans to get vaccinated and
the uptick has been a pleasant surprise
there was always a concern about are we
going to see more hesitancy
sooner on and in fact so far we haven't
seen that
health officials are aware the last 30
percent may be more vaccine hesitant
hopefully like i say what we're seeing
is a snowball effect and i think
as more and more canadians get
vaccinated you know even with the two
doses i think it just
increases their confidence overall
vaccination numbers also climbed because
canada struck contracts for tens of
millions of doses from multiple
companies
including seven million this month from
moderna we should
be grateful that they are prioritizing
canada for vaccine supply in light of
the
incredible global demand for vaccines
but that incredible global demand has
prompted the world health organization
to besiege countries like canada to
share its bounty of doses now
the ongoing vaccine crisis is a
scandalous
inequity the g7 commitment for a billion
doses will help
but critics say more is needed and
sooner to help vulnerable populations
still waiting for first doses
how is it fair that you know we are
ahead of the game and we are protecting
our populations
much much earlier compared to low-income
countries
canada has now firmed up a commitment to
share doses but ottawa's priority is
clearly to get as many canadians as
possible
fully vaccinated as soon as possible and
canadians are showing that that is their
priority too
eric sorensen global news toronto
the u.s food and drug administration is
allowing the release of 10 million doses
of johnson and johnson's coveted vaccine
from a baltimore factory that had
contamination problems
but the fda says another 60 million
doses must be thrown out
because they are not suitable for use
the agency didn't specify
exactly why factory employees
accidentally contaminated an earlier
batch of the vaccine ruining
15 million doses late today health
canada confirmed it will
not be distributing the johnson and
johnson vaccine doses
it received back in april the agency
plans to inspect the baltimore facility
later this summer with case numbers
declining in ontario the province kicked
off its much anticipated reopening plan
today
a few days earlier than expected
[Applause]
customers flocked to restaurant patios
and stores for the first time
in months under step one outdoor dining
at restaurants is allowed so is in
person shopping at non-essential stores
but
not everyone is adjusting easily some
business owners
are struggling to get staff back
i think they're waiting to see if we're
going to stay open
before they're going to come back right
because you know the staff have to come
back
to work happy to come back to work and
then get laid off after not even 10 days
and then
reapply for crb or whatever assistance
that they may need
one region in northern ontario the
porcupine health unit is delaying easing
restrictions due to a surge in cases
the rest of the province will stay in
phase one for at least three weeks to
assess the impact on public health
ontario businesses have been locked down
since april
an outbreak at calgary's foothills
hospital has grown to 33 people
including 10 who are fully vaccinated
22 of the cases are linked to the more
contagious delta variant
the outbreak involves both patients and
staff in three separate units
alberta health services says one person
is in intensive care
and it's monitoring the situation
closely the province's top doctor is
emphasizing that fully vaccinated
individuals
can still get sick a new canadian study
is tracking trends in covid19 and
vaccine safety and effectiveness in
youth
the research project funded by the
federal government will collect data
from children's hospitals across the
country
investigators are looking for symptoms
in youth caused by the disease including
a rare condition called multi-system
inflammatory syndrome
which can cause swelling and heart
problems they're also examining how
vaccination could reduce covet 19
hospitalizations and severe illness
among youth
the supreme court of canada has ruled
documents related to the estate of
murdered ontario billionaires
barry and honey sherman be made public
in a unanimous decision the court says
the media can access files pertaining
to who would inherit the couple's money
and assets the estate wanted to have
files sealed arguing safety and privacy
concerns
but in its ruling the court reaffirmed
that court proceedings are open to the
public
the prominent couple was found dead in
their toronto home in december of 2017.
the murders remain under investigation
the leader of the people's party of
canada maxine bernier was arrested in
manitoba
today step out of the vehicle and place
you under arrest right now
yeah bernier was put in handcuffs and
taken into custody for participating in
a rally against covid 19 restrictions
just outside saint pierre he's charged
under the public health act he was
ticketed earlier in the day
during a rally in another community
bernie says he plans to
fight the charges magic mushrooms are
moving
into the mainstream coming up the
research into how they could
improve mental health
now to a boom in the mushroom industry
the psychedelic
kind for years they were part of the war
on drugs but more recently
research shows they can help with
conditions like anxiety
depression and trauma technically magic
mushrooms are illegal
but clinical trials are about to begin
in canada as robin gill reports those
who have undergone this therapy
are showing promising results
the first thing you notice about lori
brooks is how she's amazingly at peace
for someone who has terminal cancer i've
had three years to get
used to the fact that i'm most likely
not going to survive this
that acceptance followed her treatment
with a mind-altering drug
psilocybin also known as magic mushrooms
the six-hour immersive experience with
the therapist by her side
extinguished her anxiety did you think
that this was going to help you deal
with dying
yes so i feel like i'm living
on bonus time right now
this lab in nanaimo bc numinous is the
first company
in canada to legally harvest these
hallucinogenics
it is set to begin clinical trials on
patients using
macro doses the brain has all these
pathways much like a highway
when a patient has a psychedelic
experience different parts of the brain
that weren't connecting
now do this greater neuroplasticity
enhances the brain's ability
to reorganize thought patterns to deal
with anxiety
depression or trauma groups at johns
hopkins university and other ivy league
institutions in the united states have
been studying
psilocybin assisted psychotherapy for
smoking cessation
for depression for anxiety associated
with a life-threatening illness
like like individuals with cancer and
have all shown
dramatic benefits in terms of
improvements in mental disorder symptoms
among people dealing with mood disorders
even everyday stress and anxiety
the micro dosing market is picking up
it's an illegal
gray area though as the name suggests
these capsules are not
nearly as strong as the dose used in
therapy and the research shows
they're not habit forming 100 is not
addictive mushrooms are known for being
a
pain reliever just like opioids can be
however one is addictive and one is not
um a mushrooms psychedelics can act as a
natural addiction disruptor
the first time lori brooks took a trip
it was an underground session with a
therapist present
she's now one of a handful of patients
enrolled in a special federal program
where she's legally allowed to dose you
would never know that
looking at me that i have cancer and
that i'm probably
in the last stages of cancer the disease
doesn't consume the time she has left
it's just moved to the periphery of her
life where she
says it belongs robin gill global news
abbotsford bc there's still so much we
don't know about magic mushrooms to
learn more watch robin's full story on
the new reality
tomorrow at 7 p.m 5 p.m in bc
right here on global still ahead europe
kicks off its biggest sporting event
scoring
a pandemic first
queen elizabeth made g7 world leaders
laugh today during a photo op
and royal reception at eden park it's
the first time u.s president joe biden
has met the queen since taking office
it's also the first time the 95 year old
monarch and
other members of the royal family have
taken part in the talks
they're staying away from politics
focusing on pandemic recovery
and the planet's health soccer's
european championship
euro 2020 kicks off in rome today after
being postponed
by a year because of the pandemic
[Music]
tens of thousands of fans are expected
to attend matches in 11 different
countries
foreign travelers can apply for visas
with quarantine exemptions in place for
ticket holders
spectators must show they are fully
vaccinated and
have received a negative covet test
there will also
be limited capacity and staggered
arrival times at stadiums
a twice vandalized gondola reopens in bc
next what's being done to stop future
sabotage
check this out a selfie from mars it's
china's first mars rover posed next to
its landing platform
it was taken with a wireless camera that
the rover placed on the surface of the
red planet
before rushing back for the shot china
is the second country to land and
operate a spacecraft
on mars after the united states it's
remote controlled
solar-powered and will study the surface
and atmosphere of mars
visitors to a popular tourist attraction
in bc can
soon take selfies of their own again the
cetasky gondola reopened today in
squamish
the site was shut for eight months after
two separate acts of vandalism
both times cables were severed causing
the gondola cars to crash to the ground
and both cases are still unsolved
global's paul johnson is in squamish
tonight
paul this day was a long time coming
far for a lot of people who were
following this story
the first time this cable was cut people
were very surprised
but the second time this cable was
sabotaged
people were shocked and a lot of people
were wondering if this attraction
would ever reopen but here we are now
getting to this point
was a costly and unprecedented challenge
they had to get a new cable made
in switzerland and installed here and
they had to replace
all of the cabin cars and then on top of
that
because the saboteur is still at large
they had to create and deploy what is
likely the most
sophisticated surveillance system for
any gondola
in north america if not anywhere in the
world here's the general manager
not that we don't expect something bad
to happen ever in our future
but our posture now is in anticipation
of that we've created something that
truly is uh
extraordinary and somewhat of unheard of
outside of
you know industries such as the nuclear
space you know so
we're prepared as anybody could possibly
be and that i can say with great
confidence
so as to this saboteur this is still an
open and very active investigation it's
believed that both times
the cable was cut it was done using a
simple angle grinder
kind of tool that you could get at any
tool supply store
the motive is still unknown but the
consequences for this person
or any people involved will be very
severe
if caught it's worth pointing out that
the second time the cable was cut
there was a night security guard here
who was nearly killed when that cable
came down
farah paul johnson in squamish bc thank
you paul
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm farin asser
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
canada is the town of redcliffe in
southern alberta
we love seeing your canada so please
keep sending us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
robin gill will be with you tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other
[Music]